Jess you are a mom of two boys and and
having a show like this does it make you
more or less nervous for those teenage
years to roll around I am a
devastatingly nervous about it I cannot
believe you would humiliate dad like
that dude
I don't have a death wish Michelle has
two boys too yeah are older than my boys
so she's like I'm in the teenagers she's
there right you're oh you're there now
yes God I mean oh it's terrifying what
what's gonna happen to these kids and
what they have to go through in puberty
and yeah it's hard being a kid I tell my
eight-year-old that all the time I'm
like dude it's hard being eight I get it
and then I'm gonna help him see my I'm
like it's hard being 41 you know and
he's just looking at me like what
you don't matter
people are gonna start asking questions
we have to get our story straight
congratulations on season two of Cruel
Summer there is so much excitement about
this second go around I mean how would
you describe this season in just a
couple words
friendship yeah okay I love the Loyalty
I like that one I keep pinching myself
to make sure I'm not dreaming
well I'm lucky that I came along and
corrupted you can we get a season three
do you two want to continue the stories
I mean we really want a season three we
think we have something super special
here with the show and the three
timelines and the Dual perspectives and
the period of it all and the mystery and
and I I we're hoping that the audience
Tunes in for two so that freeform has no
choice but to pick up three really
that's really what we're hoping for you
ever wish we could go back
just undo something what do we have to
do to get a cameo from Miss Jessica Biel
for season three
you know what's so funny I'm always
trying to find a role in these these
parts Michelle's always telling me I'm
too old
too old you cannot play I did high
school anymore she wanted to play either
cater Jeanette last season and I was
like
we've aged out of that
but just is a Y2K icon I mean she like
you just thank you thank you Michelle
did you hear that an icon
no one no one
I needed her Casting I needed her doing
the other stuff
yeah she doesn't want me hanging out of
my trailer feeling like I'm a you know a
big shot keeper you know no one rocked
the low-rise jeans the white tank tops
better than Jessica meal this Kitty eye
um sunglasses right skinny sunglasses
and the really skinny eyebrows one of
the things that I loved most about this
season is that early 2000 fashion and
was it important for you to really hit
the nail with that making sure the
clothing pieces the articles of
accessories were spot on
I mean it's these things really only
work in the details like to your point
and
our show
because it relies so heavily on this
aesthetic everything has to be perfect
because everyone's too clever you know
we were all there I you know if that's
not real I know right or that those low
hanger genes are not low enough yeah we
all know what we all know these things
and it's so funny because our our lovely
young cast it's like they've never seen
these things before right they're
looking at walk men they're looking
they're looking at sea rocks what is
this thing it's so funny
um but yeah it has to be perfect we have
to we have to put the best team in place
all the time to get particularly the
fashion and the music and the production
design on point I mean you Jeff and your
husband are Y2K icons Y2K icon dinosaur
to them like a dinosaur like prehistoric
to these kids I mean we call them kids
they're not they're these like
incredibly young adults amazing young
adults but
I do feel like a dinosaur sometimes
rather yeah
is there anything that you snagged from
set fashion wise either of you guys
what did you steal Michelle I I know you
sold nothing
you know more than anything when you
walk to onto a set like in this season
when we walked into uh Megan Landry
Sandy Sadie's room you look around and
you're like I had that I had that yeah
yeah I had it's that stuff it's really
nostalgic for you and of course she
walks in and she's like what's this this
is weird this is strange it was more
that I'm sadly I don't fit into their
clothes but the stuff in the room is
what's really in the the sets that you
really look at like even the camcorder
remember
right like they were heavy you had to
hold them I think this is this is what
we were you should have stolen like the
jewelry you know the like little jewelry
pieces and the friendship bracelets and
all that we really made a mistake we did
listen just go to a Taylor Swift concert
you'll get all the friendship bracelets
yeah oh that's true